laurent cesari professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras
nord cesari bonjour et merci des frais
en direct avec nous alors le procès de
donald trump s'est donc ouvert hier avec
en guise d'introduction une vidéo
retraçant les événements du 6 janvier
dernier
comment qualifier cette levée de rideau
le très spectaculaire
ça a commencé par un appel aux
sentiments assez compréhensible que d'en
commander comme les communes ford avec
cette vidéo qui effectivement
rappel des faits tout tout à fait réel
et montrer sous leur angle le plus
choquant et ensuite ça a continué avec
le la plaidoirie si j'ose dire de
sénateurs dont le fils s'était suicidé à
la veille des vacances de noël qui
étaient venus avec un autre de ses
enfants voir au congrès voire l'époque
la nation des résultats la pauvre faute
de l'abbé çà et là plus jamais voulu se
tourner et l'aviation privée play
retourner look évidemment là aussi c'est
très très émotionnel mais c'est une
stratégie d'un tacle parfaitement
compréhensible alors si républicains se
sont joints aux 50 démocrate apparenté à
ce procès ils ont ils ont jugé
inconstitutionnel un premier vote ce qui
laisse entrevoir un acquittement
puisqu'on leur appel la condamnation de
donald trump appose une majorité
qualifiée de 60
cette voie est ce que vous pensez qu'un
plus grand nombre de républicains
pourrait se rallier aux démocrates
je crois vous avez exactement 10 qui
laisse présager un acquittement puisque
le site il ya quarante quatre sénateurs
qui estime que le procès lui-même n'est
pas constitutionnel quelles raisons le
silence et de condamner puisqu'il action
même leur semble alors leur semble
illégitime et illégale la performance
des avocats de donald trump a suscité de
nombreuses critiques une défense décousu
agressive à votre avis quels arguments
pour et il présentait pour innocenter
l'ancien président alors il ya deux
arguments jusqu'ici le premier vienne
tomber c'était la constitutionnalité de
du procès le deuxième il peut paraître
un peu étrange et en même temps
connaissant le train est pas totalement
mais il est peut-être pas totalement
faux c'est que il était absolument
convaincu que hilal que les résultats
étaient été été le four et vu la manière
dont il se fait dans d'autres il s'est
fait quand c'est tout au long de sa
présidence on peut supposer que cette
idée a priori la vraisemblable était
vraiment dans son cerveau que ça c'est
impossible à démontrer
évidemment on peut y aura une masse
d'arguments contre et le troisième
argument qui vont employer
c'est le premier ramenant savoir le
droit de le droit de dire ce qu'on veut
mais là évidemment les divas pas
vraiment des difficultés parce que ce
sont des paroles qui ont quand même le
susciter des actes donc là la défense et
quand même avec les arguments difficile
votre sentiment par rapport à ce procès
on la veut il a été qualifié de
politique par les avocats de donald
trump est ce que c'est important comme
le soulignent les démocrates de voir
donald trump condamner pour qu'il ne se
représente pas dans l'avenir aux
élections américaines
l'aspect politique
certains étaient deux choses d'une part
et ça se comprend tout à fait il veut il
va le créer un précédent de faire en
sorte je crois que vous l'avez montré
dans la zone des premières images faire
en sorte que président autres le moment
de l'élection en novembre et le moment
week où il termine son mandat de puisse
pas faire n'importe quoi
clément est sec ce qui est
compréhensible y avait aussi la volonté
de faire en sorte qu'ils ne puissent pas
se représenter et là ça serait possible
parce que même si à pas les voix pour
renault beachmint on peut utiliser le 14
et dans le monument deuxième faction qui
empêche à à fonctionner un agent de
l'état d'inciter à la sédition et la
manifestation et majorité pour ça et on
se dit là est la conséquence de sa 91e
c'est chaud c'est que les agents conseil
ne peut plus se représenter justement à
des fonctions publiques
mais il ya une fois à considérer c'est
que c'est que même si trump peut être
empêché de se représenter ce qu'ils
savent en une sorte de plus possible que
keanu pitchouns d'or envolée due forme
faut pas oublier qu'il a une famille des
enfants notamment le fils qui est très
pugnace et qui lui aussi songé à une
carrière politique
merci beaucoup laurent césar et de nous
avoir accordé du temps je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras